hostilities between armenia and
azerbaijan
have continued into a third day in
what's the worst flare-up
of an old territorial dispute since a
truce was agreed a quarter of a century
ago
violence exploded between the nations on
sunday
with both laying claim to the
nagorno-karabakh
region let's show you some exclusive
pictures we've received now these are
filmed by an rt crew
in nagorno-karabakh you can see parts of
a drone
that was shot down by armenian armed
forces during the fighting
our crew is so far the only media
granted access
to the area by the armenian authorities
our correspondent igor jidanov not so
long ago sent this report
right now we're between the positions of
the armenian army which is over there
and the azerbaijani forces which are
stationed right over this hill
and here is the debris of a massive
unmanned drone that was shut down
by the armenian air defense this is the
main piece but not the only one in fact
there's still
a distinctive stench of burning up in
the air which means it was shot down
literally
hours before we arrived here in fact
we're the first
international news crew allowed here by
the armenian forces the earth here
is scorched and everybody has to walk
over
huge like pieces of metal like this and
well
this marks yet another day of deadly
clashes between
armenia and the disputed region of
nagorno-karabakh
and azerbaijan backed by turkey in fact
armenia accused azerbaijan of attacking
its
soil today which means that probably
conflict spilled
over the borders of this disputed region
but we're being told that we have to
hurry we have to rush it it's not safe
here so we have to wrap up
i will be bringing you more of this as
we go more of this as a
stay here i'm rigged reporting from the
disputed region of nagornikarabak
rt
you